since we're this is a presidential honor
I want to go back to 2009 you're at the
White House what are you thinking when
you're playing in front of the Obamas
I mean I'm super nervous I mean I look
back at the video and like I'm just
grinning like this the entire like move
my mouth I'm thinking to myself why am i
grading so much I should tone it down
but I'm like I can't I'm just like not a
very nervously but it was just amazing I
it was a wonderful opportunity to be in
that room to meet President Obama to
perform this song that Lim had written
you know we didn't know what was going
to become of any of that we didn't even
know who's gonna be filmed or seen in
that way we were just happy to be in
that room yeah that day was like a sneak
preview of how surreal life would get we
started by splitting a van with James
Earl Jones to the White House and I was
like the day could ended there and it
would have been like the highlight of my
life with James Earl Jones and then you
know the performance went as well as it
went and the video went viral and here
we are give people a sense of the risk
of that I mean nobody's seen this and it
was not obviously a form that people
were expecting and you're by the way in
the video you're basically spitting at
the president yeah because I was there I
was probably as nervous as I've ever
been in my life in that moment because I
was both premiering something new
something only my closest collaborators
and my wife had heard my wife and I but
I also was really proud of it and I
wanted it to go well and I also remember
thinking like if this room doesn't get
it you know we'll see how it goes but I
remember how well the soundcheck went
and I remember we met the Obamas before
we performed so it was like they didn't
have a sense of what was coming and it
was just it was it was an electric
moment and it was a sneak preview of
what was what was gonna come I just you
know there was a lot of work between
writing one song and writing a whole
show yeah we're gonna get to that Tommy
you grew up in this area now you're here
getting a Kennedy Center Honor I mean
what does that like it
not something that I was thinking about
when I was six years old you know going
to see the Nutcracker
why am I dressed in a bowtie upset
pictures of me like in that in that
hallway I mean it's you know it's
something that I find meaningful in a
way that I think Linda's maybe had a
chance to experience being someone who
has had his hometown be the place where
he's made his work I remember going to
Miami with Alex when we took in the
heights there and seeing what that felt
like and because you know my experience
here and taking this show which I feel
like is so much of Who I am
and having it be in that same hallway
and you know in you know walking down
that Hall of flags and seeing a show
that I had something to do at play there
it feels both out-of-body and and yet
like an arrival and so it's been
incredibly moving for me I mean the red
carpet the bust of of Kennedy and I mean
the iconic things of your yeah I mean
it's what every six-year-old dreams of
right yeah someday I'll take a musical
you know when I was growing up at that
time I was playing soccer and baseball
and chasing some ball around some field
it didn't occur to me that people made
shows I didn't know anybody that did
that so if I saw a movie I wasn't
waiting for the credits to see if there
was a director or a writer I just
thought that's nice that this story is
being presented to me in some way so it
was just it was it was this other world
that I didn't know existed and the
Kennedy Center made it available to me
as as a young kid and so to be back
there as someone who makes stuff sharing
with other young kids really just
knocked me out and there are awards
given in categories then there is this
award which is basically being given to
you all because you have done something
well I'll read what it says trailblazing
creators of a transformative work that
defies category so they created a new
category because what you've the best
way to win in a war yeah I mean that's
amazing it's also wonderful that you
know the Broadway theater American
musical theater is something that is
uniquely America and and taking its
roots in and very mer
in musical forms its swing music dance
music of the Jazz era popular music of
the 40s and 50s and so it is a it is a
very American form but in its most
crystal form it's also a something
that's all about collaboration it's not
a singular effort and so the Broadway
musical is based on minds coming
together problem-solving creating being
inspired and so it's great to be honored
in that way too because it really is a
team effort
but they are saying teams have worked
before so let's talk about your team
they're saying teams have worked before
but turns out this team has done
something no other team has done before
well I think it's a couple things we're
speaking in words that maybe our new
words dance language musical language
story language its aggressive
storytelling and it's forward-thinking
but it's about something that happened
to all of us and is imprinted in our DNA
so I think that's also part of the power
of the whole thing is that we're taking
something that people feel so deeply it
resonates in us so deeply the American
Journey the struggles of the family the
fights of both independence and voice
those are things that we all know in our
DNA
we're just saying it in a way that feels
new but reminds us of something that we
know already a new way that we'd
forgotten we knew right Annie way to
touch something old and elemental
alright let's talk about the process
take me and where is it happening Lynn
is it happening at a breakfast table is
it happening in texts where is this
collaboration taking place in its
various different times for the first
few years it was just happening in my
head on vacations various vacations
because it was always it would always
pop up then it was like the ghost of
Hamilton would be like hey write write a
song for King George which got written
on my honeymoon and I think finally I'd
written like two or three songs and I
finally I performed one of the songs at
a fundraiser for ARS Nova which is a
theater we work with a lot and Tommy was
like we should start setting deadlines
because if you're gonna average a song a
year this is gonna take a long time and
so we set our first deadline was a
concert we did at Lincoln Center's Jazz
at Lincoln Center I was on Hamilton's
birthday January 11th and we said
and put a mark in the sand and said all
right six months from now we're gonna
perform everything you've got and so I
wrote I write to the deadline and so I
mean I remember we did like nine or ten
songs there and it was I got a great
piece of advice from playwright John
Weidman he said don't try to put the
whole book on stage just write the parts
you think you want to see in a musical
and so in that concert we did helpless
him meeting his wife for the first time
we didn't say no to this the affair
we did we did my shot right-hand man
meeting George Washington rap battles we
did the rap battles just testing that
out with the mics and seeing how that
would play we closed with the opening
number and because we didn't have the
duel yet and and I remember singing the
opening number as our closing number and
seeing Andy in the audience something
like this
[Laughter]
and when you're watching that Andy what
all of that new stuff is coming into
your head how are you processing it are
you are your feet moving already aren't
the beat the beat was everywhere and
that's what is so special about what
Lynn and Alex do is that whether it's a
ballad tempo or the fastest tempo in the
show the organic beat underneath move
moves us emotionally and so it's easy to
dance to it so there's many a number
that these folks write together that
that end up not dancing but they could
they dance in their souls because
they're about action they're about
things that must be said or must be done
and so as I was hearing the music like
every single song inspired me I was also
really transported immediately by not
knowing what it was like it wasn't a
linear normal musical it could have been
a hip-hop song cycle that was a record
and like that and so so being that it
was so out of the box in that it wasn't
trying to be a musical it actually even
exploded my brain even more because then
it then you could throw all the pants
against the wall because they took the
rules out of it already and and so that
was really really inspiring to me and
then the backdrop to their concert was
the New York skyline I mean it was in
front of the window
Jasleen container and so there I was
with my wife on like a perfect Manhattan
night hearing this moving thing and I
and it that was actually like these guys
for the White House like the first step
for me to say oh this is gonna be unreal
and unreal journey and so then Alex
where's the story go from there
it usually starts when Lynne emails the
demo and you come out of the blue the
demo you're just you're getting you got
a LinkedIn notification then suddenly
you got but what's amazing is that with
Lynne's demo it's like the spark is
always there like there's always a hook
there's always something that just grabs
you and you know my job is to interpret
basically like the song comes and then
I'm like okay how do we get a band to
play this how do we get singers to
harmonize in chords to support what the
story is what to support what the melody
is so it's for me it's intuition but
it's also just a lot of chemistry and
that that's what I think all four of us
have because you could pick for other
people a different choreographer or a
different director or a different a
songwriter and it wouldn't click in this
way but for whatever reason there's just
a certain kind of DNA certain kind of
common language amongst all of us that
it all just kind of clicks in you know
it's just because hemos for a second
like Linds demos are gold and because
they continue to evolve and grow but I
remember one time I was at the gym on
the treadmill and I couldn't figure out
a number for in the heights and I went
back to the earliest demo that lit that
Lynn had sent and the song had changed a
great deal but it just had an essence in
it you're like oh that's what his truth
is that's what he's trying to say so
then you can go back to the evolved work
after it has changed and still rich
retrofit Lynn's instinct in there so
those demos are really almost like a
biography I think of his composing mind
so that those original demo is a kind of
the Nugget of the thing and the thing
about these demos is in a way it's like
a it's a charting of the course of an
idea so it's it's like a diary and a lot
of our job collectively in my job in
particular with each of these three is
to remind them of where they started you
know what
what was the impulse what was the
instinct what was the spar
because sometimes you can work a thing
too much all of us can and sometimes the
best note is go back sometimes the best
note is just leave it alone it's already
there and I think that there's so much
faith and trust in each other that you
can bring in something that might be a
seed and you also sometimes can bring in
a forest like Lynn has sent us something
we're like so we're done let's move on
when Andy showed us room where it
happened I was like what's the next song
because there's nothing to contribute
here you know so I think you also have
to you have to be there for each other
in that way and try to understand
through shared experience what that
person might need at that moment and and
again the four of us for our show are
just you know four of dozens and
hundreds of people at this point our
designers who have to also translate
this our company the you know the
musicians the producers who are trying
to support and help shape and nourish
this so we are you know where there's
part of this larger organism but we also
have very particular responsibilities to
make sure that we're always really clear
on what story we're trying to tell and
how we're trying to tell it yeah and I
want to get at the idea of how you
convey what the four of you were able to
create into that huge company and and
and how that process works but let me
ask you this though Lynne so creative
people have strong views but you all
have a collaboration where as Tommy was
just saying he reminds you of yourself
if you maybe get lost in the weeds or in
that but how does that work when in
collaboration if you you're putting
yourself out there creation is a naked
experience and then somebody says now
that's you got a how do you not
basically get on each other's nerves
well I think that we respond to each
other's energy in a way that's really
positive Tommy has a way of setting a
room where the best idea in the room
wins and you know if I bring in a song
and I see Andy's already love to his
feet and alex is already playing with
variations I'm like okay we're pretty
far along the course by bringing a song
and it's quiet I go okay a swing and a
Miss and but these guys are never
prescriptive it's never the song needs
to do this or the song
to do this it's alright here was my we
can go back to basics of here was my
intent here is what you're hearing and
how do we shorten the distance between
my intent and and what you're getting
and that's sort of always what we're
doing and then that happens in a larger
sense when we get an audience it's we're
trying to know everything that is being
hailed as an innovation is an attempt
bias to eliminate any distance between
the story and an audience you know
anything that would be like this is
other this is not my experience I feel
like I've seen this this is a history
book we're just trying to sweep all the
cobwebs away and and everything from the
music to the costumes to to everyone's
choices here are just to make it feel as
immediate and gripping as possible I
think one of the rarest things and maybe
what is the miracle of our collaboration
is that we actually do finish each other
sentences and what works for one person
innately works for the next person I
remember in our entire time doing three
shows now together the only time Lynne
ever said to me that doesn't look like I
thought it was gonna look when I heard
music in my head happened one time like
of all the times that have made the
choice to physicalize things in a
certain way and so I think that we just
innately follow the same river like we
are just in that that that course flying
it together and it just makes sense for
all of us it's not like your sensibility
is totally different from mine so let me
figure you out somehow our scent our our
instincts just meet yeah and there's a
Venn diagram that intersects at the core
if you were to take how the four of us
approach the work or see the work and so
you have this thing in the center of it
that feels like it's got these four
layers and then there are things that
Andy can do and see that I never could
and things that Lynn can do and see that
we never could and same with Alex and so
that actually makes the thing broader
based because then diagrams are always
about what's the thing that intersects
in the middle but if you look at it and
think about how much bigger the shape is
because of that contribution then I
think you're growing the organism and I
also feel that each of us believe
because we sort of respectively lead our
own departments right that's Alex
running the band and teaching the
company you know how to articulate in
story tell with music and then we
collaborate on that Andy obviously with
his department
you know my feeling about it is we all
understand instinctively that the stakes
can be high and the temperature of the
room can be low and that you can make
excellent things with harmony that this
can be proof that it's possible to make
something of high quality that didn't
result from acrimony or you know or
raising your voice if nothing else
that's one of the things that I hope it
becomes part of the legacy of the show
making a Broadway musical I think it's
such an interesting art form because you
have all of these different designers
that are all trying to serve the piece
you know you have the choreographer you
have the lighting designer you have the
costumes Hamilton is a show where I felt
like every single designer was all going
towards the same direction because the
material was so strong and so visceral I
remember thinking to myself like I do
not want to ruin this because everything
that Lynne has given us is so amazing
and I know that every designer brought
their a-game because they all wanted to
serve this piece but I really do think
as Andy said it was a miracle that
everybody all was going in the same
direction looking at the same goal
feeling the same feelings and seeing the
same final product we brought you
together because we wanted to tell you
something
you ruined it I don't think it's gonna
fly Alex was there ever a dark moment in
all creative maybe you had them
individually but was there ever a moment
where you thought about having States
debts assumed by the federal government
that's not gonna fly I remember the
first time Lynne brought the demo to me
and I heard it and it was my first
reaction was I couldn't tell it was
trying to be tongue-in-cheek was it
trying to be funny
I was so taken because it was so
different I didn't know what to expect
and even when we performed it here at
the White House I remember a lot of the
reactions where it was little there's a
lot of laughter happening and I remember
thinking to myself oh how are people
want to interpret this because even
after that performance whenever I would
explain Hamilton to people it's
impossible to explain it you say to them
it's a hip-hop show about a founding
father and everyone just kind of [ __ ]
their head and they would say okay
that's interesting but but I said you
have to see it you have to hear it and
then they don't understand so it was
until a year later until I heard my shot
and I heard that chant I am NOT throwing
away my shot and I started to see oh my
god Lynne is dead serious about this
and it really started to fill me with
something and it was like American pride
there was something about that that I
just felt oh my god I never pictured the
founding fathers with this kind of
energy with this kind of passion and
drive and perseverance and it started to
wake up my understanding of American
history in a way that I did not expect
now given the journey you on you've been
on it must be actually kind of
refreshing for somebody to say
Hamilton what's that because I mean it's
so much a part of the conversation now
Lynne tell me when you're doing this
creation is there a shorthand you use I
mean when you're talking the four of you
how did you are there ways that you it's
just whatever makes Andy feel excluded
no gosh I don't know I think that um I
think the shorthand is you know this is
we've worked together a long time now we
we all met in one two thousand seven
five five 2005 and so we've been through
lots of different experiences and so you
bring all of that to bear it's it's
really like a marriage or a band or
anything else and so you know my
favorite thing to do in this
collaboration is when I get to bring a
new song into the room and let everybody
at it you know it's it's because I know
my work is gonna get better as a result
as being in the same room as these guys
and and and then here's the other funny
thing that happens to me because again I
was I was in this one so I didn't see
the show for a while you know I didn't
see it and I remember seeing opening
number for the first time with with my
alternate Javier Munoz on and me sitting
in the audience and there were there are
things you can't see from the eye of the
hurricane and I I think the moment that
moved me to tears so much like right off
the bat was the closing moment of the
opening number
and it's Alexander Hamilton bum and
Hamilton is looking out and everyone
else has their heads bowed I didn't know
that happened because I was being
Hamilton and it's so moving on so many
levels to me it speaks to how Hamilton
is just about to start the journey of
this story and
one else in the story knows how it ends
and it just gives I mean just gooseflesh
every time I see it and the caveat to
that story is that the single day the
day I moved to New York City I sat in
the front row the mezzanine and solder
on Robyn's Broadway and drum Robbins was
my ultimate Idol core graphically and in
dance and that's how the number ends and
so I was quoting the number that made me
want more than anything to be in the
Broadway theater they the full company
and West Side Story with it with a bow
of their heads and so I was literally
just paying homage to the person who
inspired me the most saying let's follow
in that person's footsteps and Robbins
is one of the first classes of the
Kennedy Center Honors so it was like
amazing this weekend to see that the
pictures of him I think what Andy's
speaking to also is something that we
all feel very deeply which is what's
always slightly in Congress about people
that talk about our show as new or fresh
or innovative because it is the sum of
all of our parts and the stuff that
we're made of our moments like that are
fiddler on the roof' you know our rent
and this show is Sweeney Todd and gypsy
and Oklahoma and all of these things as
well as the the music and the
information that we took in through
films you know the matrix and you know
ratatouille we were talking about the
other day and the music so it's all of
those things can exist here and I think
what we're trying to say is bring it in
bring all of that in make the door wider
and and you can find something that
reflects back your your experience in a
way that you didn't necessarily think
could could exist in the hallowed
theatre right you can still where you
can respect the theater more than
anything by acknowledging what came
before and bringing that to your own
Sensibility sometimes in life I think
the ego many things insecurities makes
us unable to look at something else and
admit you're inspired by it to admit
like oh that guy is great I want to I
want to just bask in that and we do that
all I think pretty well like we are very
open about the things that that we are
that inspire us that that we idolize
performers the accomplishments the songs
the musical styles and most of those
things were built out of something else
the need for somebody to articulate in
song and so those needs that were
created in song 50 years ago 100 years
ago 10 years ago those needs still exist
in us so there's this circular spin art
thing that's happening in Hamilton we're
sort of revisiting things that made us
learn how to live our lives and both
artistically and in humanity and of
course that's what's connecting with all
of us because you're pulling something
out of us as well that we have a moment
that that is connecting in our lives to
some have you been surprised Alex have
you been surprised that people it's I
don't know if it's like the old story
about the blind man and the elephant I
mean so many people you know where one
touches and says oh the elephant is like
the Tusk and the other person touches
the foot and says the elephant is like
the foot so many people with Hamilton
pick different parts about it and have
this deep energy about it has that been
surprising I don't know that it's been
surprising but I think there's so much
to love about Hamilton there's so many
different things that one can pull out
of it everything I think if you ask all
four of us what Hamilton is about what
you will get four different answers
you can ask everyone everyone out there
what they think Hamilton is about or
what their favorite part is and what
their interpretation of it is you'll
have different answers and I think
that's one of the best parts about art
but is that there is no real finite
answer even the Creator might have a
thing that he was trying to get across
but someone else will pull something
else out of it that they might not have
been expecting and that is what is
wonderful about art it's like looking at
a sculpture and one of my favorite
things to do is to walk around the
entire thing and observe it from every
angle and look at the back of the head
and see what the hair looks like from
back there I look down at the foot and
see what that is and that there's
something to be gained and some beauty
to be seen from every aspect and even
for me I watched the show to this day
and see something that I hadn't seen
before
I'll see a step that Andy did that I
didn't realize was there I'll see a
placement of an actor that didn't know
that Tommy had placed them there so
there's always something new to see and
that's one of my favorite things about
what it is that we do it reminds me of
being a kid and listening to a record
and upon the 50th time hearing a song
realizing oh I didn't realize the bass
did that at that
and it just keeps giving so when are you
are you're still collaborating on this
work I mean once this energy and this
thing is going but when do you put your
pen when do you put the pen down and the
test is over oh I put the pen down when
we opened pretty much I mean but but the
collaboration doesn't end right because
Hamilton being what it is it requires
lots of decisions every day and and and
but no one tells you when you embark on
a musicals that you're married to the
people you made the music with in a real
way for the rest of your life because
you're the custodians of the work in
theatre you own the work so just the way
you know Chiara and I who co-wrote in
the heights with me still make decisions
about in the heights every day and we're
making decisions about the movie version
that is coming out now and all these
guys worked on that as well you know we
we are custodians of the work in a very
real way we're very involved in all the
tours that are going on and to the point
of casting I mean we're still we're
still crafting this show yeah the
production has an integrity and it has a
vision that is both specific and and
powerful so when we do open a new
company there is a responsibility to
cater it to their individuality and
their individual skill set without
losing the integrity of the piece and so
we've been very good at keeping our
hands on the clay because that's a
difficult process too because we want
somebody in London or Arizona to see the
same idea we don't want it to feel like
it's third generation Xerox copy or
something and Tommy says this all the
time actually the Richard Rodgers is
only a 1300 seat theater so more people
are experiencing Hamilton on tour than
they are on Broadway I mean they are the
they're the true the tours are really
the true ambassadors of the show at this
point right and tell me Tommy how do you
convey what you this special thing which
people are Cannell witness in the
conversation you've had here to the
broader company to and and to other
cities so those are the days Tommy makes
everyone cry it's the best because he's
so eloquent you move them to tears thank
you you know I think that's so cool
that's one of the things that I love
about the opportunity to go and make
these new companies is that we're still
refining I might say something giving an
adjustment to
actor in an audition someone who might
not even get the part that I realize is
a better crystallization of an idea then
I've been using for the last couple
years and so you bring that into the
room so we get better at what we do that
evolves and then I think it's really
incumbent on on us and on the other
people that are helping us mount these
tours from our departments to to talk
about some of those more ineffable
things to talk about the ideas to never
compare one company to the other but to
talk about where an idea was incepted
where the thing was created and why it
was created because if you understand
the storytelling then you understand
what Andy is doing and if you and if you
were able to imbue and endow that
company with that kind of information
then their ability to bring a to any of
these cities that we get to visit is
just as full and complete as it can be
so if they understand the source code
then they can get in on it if you lived
an experience with somebody you don't
have to explain it you both lived it and
so like even in our original company we
had worked with probably 75 to 85
percent of that company on other shows
so they knew all of our shorthand they I
wouldn't have to really explain a damn
step because my associate Stephanie
would just understand what I was trying
to accomplish so there wasn't the need
for words when you had relationships
that were years and years old so as we
go to new companies those relationships
are actually now brand new for the most
part so we have to have them go to
school with us so to speak so even if
it's George Washington doing it you're
using the vocabulary of all kinds of
difference previous dance yeah but also
but also previous relationships yeah
like Chris Jackson like we have an
experience with Chris Jackson so you go
into the staging of the show in a way
that's totally different words that were
totally a different groundwork then
somebody who you're actually meeting and
developing a new relationship will
describe what how Washington moves on
the stage well just describe how you
would explain the way Washington because
I mean like right-hand-man is a great
example because my right-hand man
was always supposed to be like
Washington stepping out of an oil
painting like we see him
the thing that is in an oil painting
he's so grand he's a God to us and the
bullets never hit him and and so the way
that I always imagined right-hand man to
be it was like a pop-up video like the
h1 pop-up video and like Washington
steps out of his own oil painting and
the pop-ups continue all around him he
can he goes back into it he goes back
out of it and so throughout the show
there's these different concepts for
number two number but Washington was
quite easy because Washington rides on
that stallion and never gets hit by a
bullet
so he actually separates himself from
the rest of the cast and that number
that's I've literally never heard you
describe it that way before which is
amazing because what's funny for me is
the fun of writing writing
right-hand-man was it was exactly
pulling Washington down off the oil
painting it was let's not meet
Washington standing Crossing the
Delaware somehow not falling off this
tiny canoe let's meet him being like
money I don't have enough troops and
we're losing which is the opposite of
how he has painted in every portrait in
the exceptional thing about all those
details that are flying through his head
those diesels are flying through his
head well bullets are flying out his
head yeah and so he's able to do like 10
things at once like that's the character
I wanted to develop was somebody who
could think like Hamilton on ten levels
while he's doing another action well and
and Hamilton is so much about pride and
hubris and so you have this great figure
coming out and saying in my first battle
I got my butt kicked which is you have
the deity teaching a lesson in humility
I won't tell you what you've read but I
think that what you're hitting on
something and I think that these three
are speaking to it really well that this
city is a series of monoliths you know I
grew up in Northern Virginia in the
shadow of Mount Vernon and you know
James Madison and Thomas Jefferson and
George Washington and and these beings
never feel like they actually existed
because you are only seeing them out of
human scale and what we endeavoured to
do was to make them human scale and
remind you of what it meant to be on the
ground in the visceral nosov the
movement in the vitality of the music
and in the richness of the performance
which is why the audience's can-can
because it's real it's not on some
monument let me ask you about the
audience land Meryl Streep talked about
when acting that all your pores are open
to take readings from the audience what
was that like at first and then how did
that evolve as Hamilton became what it
became well it was it was always sort of
the most thrilling ride of my life and
to play Alexander Hamilton is to eat a
fourteen course meal every night you get
to experience the entire spectrum of
human behavior you fall in love you
experience grief you fight a war you I
mean it's it's it's it is it's a dream
it's a dream role and and the weird
irony is that it's the most the two
hours at 40 minutes when I got to play
Hamilton were the most relaxing of my
day because it was the only time when I
only had one job
it required my full focus I knew that
audience made miracles happen to be in
that theater that night and you could
feel that electricity every night and
they powered the show the audience
powers the show and your job is to ride
that energy and and live a life in 2
hours and 40 minutes and it's it's I've
never experienced anything like it
Alex did with what has happened with
Hamilton do you think well this is what
I always thought art could do or have
you experienced something where you
think the reaction to it and the way
people talk about it actually this is
something that's new in my conception of
the effect or it could have on people's
lives I consider myself very lucky in
that I just follow where I'm led I go
where the heat is and I can't explain it
all I know is that I'm drawn to
something I feel a magnetic pull and I
go towards it I never worked on the show
I never work with these people because I
thought to myself oh I want to make art
and I want to make something that's
really gonna be important I just wanted
to hang out with these guys I feel like
I do best but you sit down at the piano
and and try to uh
have some fun have a dialog most of what
I do is to try to fill a space for
example Lin will write a melody and
there will be an inherent void there'll
be a bar of rest and I've think to
myself what can I do in that bar Burress
to just add a flavor to like complement
to finish a sentence to articulate a
thought and then get out of the way so
that the book will continues so that's
the way that I find ok this is how I can
contribute this is how I can accompany
this is how I get to play so for me like
to this day all I'm ever thinking about
is what would be the most fun thing to
do at this moment what would be the
thing that would make me smile what
would be the thing that my buddy who I
grew up with it when I was a kid would
listen to and be like oh I saw that
reference she did for that that
reference is the bass player of Rush all
right it's a and I say this often I feel
like everything in my life led me to
this moment and every friend that I had
and every record that I listen to and
every history book that I read whatever
it is allowed me to be able to
contribute in the way that I can to the
work that I do with these gentlemen and
I'm ever grateful for everything that
ever happened to me and it's just
because I think to myself okay I just
want to make music I just want to make
art a show powered by joy yeah pretty
good for me anyway
yeah tell me have you been surprised
about anything in the way this has been
the reaction that has come with the show
because with creation of art you create
a thing you all collaborate and then it
lives in the world the child goes out
and then it might come back with tattoos
and no ear piercings or it might come
back as a Baptist minister you just
don't know what's that experience like
and how it reacted to the way Hamilton
has become I think my job in the
rehearsal room and before we get into
the rehearsal room is to be the audience
so if it's just me and Lynn talking then
I represent the audience when I get into
the theatre my job is to listen to the
audience to read the audience to still
what they might be telling us and see
how that can inform what we're gonna put
out into the world
but at a certain point you have to
understand that the momentum that the
show is going to either generate or not
generate is beyond your control so
sometimes you're on the wave sometimes
you're paddling like heck and you can't
get on the wave and if you're on the way
of what you want to do is make sure that
you have your balance and your wits
about you to stay on it so the intensity
and the depth of people's response has
been humbling at every turn I've been
surprised by how young our audiences and
some of our youngest fans really are I
have nieces and nephews that heard
really early demos that were three and
five at the time and I thought they just
loved me a lot so they were being nice I
didn't know that eventually five and
six-year-olds all over the country and
all over the world would know every
lyric to that opening number that that
was that was stunning to me and so I
think that that has surprised me and I
just want to say you know something that
Alex was just speaking to made me think
about collaboration in a way that you
know that that feels like he's he's
touching on something really important
that maybe collaboration is when your
contribution is recognized and heard and
so we're always trying to put the thing
that makes us feel useful into the world
and sometimes the world says we don't
want it or drugs or it closes a door and
we've all heard the word no way more
than we've heard the word yes sometimes
maybe is all you need and if our job in
in collaborating with each other and
with the rest of our group is to say
maybe let me see then all of a sudden
you you're opening the door to
possibility that doesn't exist when you
already have the idea locked in your
mind is what it what it has to be and I
think that the the thought of feeling
accessed that Alex is talking about is
what this show does for every company
member who gets to move through the
physical patterns of the show and the
choreography that gets to sing these
these lyrics sing these melodies and
tell the story not only that well you
made me think of it as well as a lot of
what we do can be so solitary like I can
picture it Andy pacing in his room and
trying to congrat his death I can figure
out I can seal in with his headphones
walking across the George Washington
Bridge trying to come up with a lake you
know we all kind of followed
individual things and even when I'm in
my room writing I'm thinking to myself
what are they kind of thing well these
guys like it like will it measure about
but when we get in the room and they
finally get to hear it and it sparks
something it will either as time he said
be like yes let's continue or maybe not
this how about that instead even if it
starts that dialogue that's what I live
for and that's why I think I do theater
it's to be able to get in a room with
other people and not be alone and to be
able to like talk and to be able to just
um just have that like the transition
from solitaire to group is also both
hugely exciting and hugely daunting yeah
a guy I'll never forget that one of the
scariest moments for me in this show was
when Lynn finished the new finale that
Hamilton side of the duel and I did not
know what to do with it and like idea of
spoken word scared the heck out of me
and I pulled an all-nighter and I went
to get on the subway about 8:45 on the
way to work and I and I choreographed
out on the subway platform it just hit
me but but that for the you know he
wrote the show like the third day before
we finished rehearsals and and I and no
is the duel just before tech no ideas
we're coming right to deadline yeah
but it's but it's not idea of having to
go back into the group and say like Alex
was saying maybe it's not good enough I
get scary cuz everyone is such at the
top of their game to know where that bar
is is a little intimidating I would love
to do this all day I know you guys have
a credible deadline so just one last
question
Lynn is Hamilton still in your head the
person the person no I think the person
is gonna be alright it's funny Hamilton
exists because that story was too good
not to tell and I couldn't believe it
hadn't been told in this form it's just
it seemed like someone else would have
had this idea already and so I'm really
grateful that I found the right
collaborators to help get it out of my
head and get it out of the void and into
the world